foreign
we're live on the internet on Rumble
locals and YouTube it's June 30th 2023
it is the last day of June can you
believe it people the fastest year ever
continues to roll by I'm Dave Rubin this
is the Reuben report and we've got a
Friday Roundtable Extravaganza for you
it's a British Invasion joining me today
is journalist and Author Peter Lloyd and
uh best-selling author of seven books
he's put me to shame Douglas Murray good
to see you guys
good to see you likewise do I have to do
this show in some sort of accent or
should we uh do it regular style what
would you say hello
please
you guys the beauty of having you two on
together is that Peter your accent what
is considered what that's more that's
like a Liverpool accent right
yeah so I'm the commoner and Douglas and
Douglas is the Posh one The Classy one
yeah Douglas what is your accent for
that that's the Queen's accent the
king's accent what do we call that
it's just the way people speak
even that right there you've set me up
beautifully all right guys we're going
to get into a whole bunch of uh all the
nonsense of the week of course the big
story was yesterday the Supreme Court of
the United States has reversed
affirmative action in universities
actually removing systemic racism which
I thought was what we were always trying
to do but it's got all of a certain set
of people really going nuts right now
we'll have some reaction from people
like Michelle Obama and some of the
media Elite uh we'll talk a little bit
more about some of the other crazy woke
stuff happening and will 800 year old
senile Joe Biden actually run for a
re-election well it seems like it might
be uh derailing uh just a bit before we
get to that though just literally a
minute before we started apparently two
more Supreme Court rulings were
announced so I'm just doing this on the
Fly they have ruled the Supreme Court
has ruled for a web designer who refused
to work on same-sex weddings in Colorado
uh so that he as a private citizen is
allowed to decide who he wants to work
with I think that seems just fine you
wouldn't want a let's say a Jewish
artist having to commission Nazi
paintings for a white supremacist so
that that one seems okay but we'll find
out more and the other one which is uh
which is huge is that the Supreme Court
has struck down Biden's student loan
relief plan which seemed like it was
obviously going to happen and Biden
promised it like a week before the
election it got young people to vote for
him and apparently that one's out too
but the big one of course and we've got
some info here from NBC was affirmative
action here we go the Supreme Court
issued a 6-3 divided ruling on a pair of
challenges to affirmative action
policies at Harvard and the University
of North Carolina with potential
implications across education and Beyond
the Court ruled against the program
saying in the majority opinion that the
systems in place lack sufficiently
focused and measurable objectives
warranting the use of race unavoidably
employee race in a negative manner
involve racial stereotyping and lack
meaningful endpoints those admissions
programs cannot be reconciled with the
guarantees of the equal protection
Clause Douglas I'll start with you
because although you are British by
birth you are living in New York right
now and you you are American by heart
um I'm totally fine with this how do you
feel about removing systemic racism from
our universities well it's an
extraordinary case and I followed it
very closely for the last Almost decade
actually it's in it was in 2014 that a
group of Asian Americans start into
legal proceedings against Harvard it was
uh originally an anonymous collection of
students who had applied to the
university were eminently qualified and
were turned down now they noticed among
other things something very interesting
which is although the number of students
Harvard who were Asian Americans had
remained constant in recent years the
number of Asian Americans had actually
increased in other words it was a
giveaway that there was a quota system
going on at Harvard but in which they
were deciding what percentage of certain
ethnic groups they should have at any
one point now that of course is totally
opposite to a merit-based system in
which you just you know you can include
other things in somebody's life you can
include you know the extent to which
somebody may have overcome adversity or
troubles or come from a less
socioeconomically privileged background
you can include all of that without
having racial quotas but that's what it
was doing and in recent years of courses
went all the way to the Supreme Court
Harvard tried to defend itself it said
it had Trade Secrets you bet it did uh
the trade marking down Asians on
character traits without even meeting
them uh so so that's all Extraordinary
and the Supreme Court decision this week
is historic here's the interesting thing
it's not just about Harvard and it's not
just about other American universities
this shows that that not just Harvard is
is in breach of the Constitution and
it's amputee become anti-constitutional
it's that most universities in America
are not are and here is the kicker most
corporations in America right are also
therefore in breach of the Constitution
because most corporations including ones
like Google and Facebook that have big
contracts with the government are doing
something which is unconstitutional in
their hiring process so this this has
ramifications for American society as a
whole but if I can add one thing quickly
everybody should read
the end of Clarence Thomas's judgment
which forms a 50 or so page addendum to
the main judgment as people watching
will know Judge katenji Brown Jackson
Who herself is at the Supreme Court
because she is a beneficiary
remember Biden didn't say I want to get
the best nominees and then decide to a a
point a and put forward for appointment
a black American woman no he said I want
a black American woman as the opponent
so she is a beneficiary of of this
process in her own way and she wrote the
most extraordinary kendi-esque Ibraham X
Ken dies
a statement herself
judge Thomas's uh reply to that is
devastating and saying not just that
what she is doing is effectively you
know this sort of racism in the name of
anti-racism but also points out Thomas
points out that this sets America up for
Endless grievance and on that he
couldn't be more correct what she is
suggesting what affirmative action was
was a permanent state of Perpetual
grievance competition and and the fact
that that might come to an end would be
wonderful for America and everybody else
but Peter what would these people do
without endless grievance I mean you've
written a ton about the walksters and
the ideology and the whole thing and
without grievance without somehow
solving racism of the past with racism
of today they don't seem to have much
I know they might actually have to
function on their own merits and I think
for that reason we should take a moment
of silence for the likes of Elizabeth
Warren and Rachel Rachel who are going
to find it very very difficult to get
ahead in the world but uh no all jokes
aside this is a huge win for America and
I'm so delighted I know I'm just from
Brit in another country but I am really
really delighted and I'm so delighted
that look at this laughs oh wow look at
that I'm having my own little mini party
here just to celebrate the fact that
that even happened because that's how
good it is
that's nice because it's also right
before July 4th which I know is not a
great holiday for you guys in terms of
us leaving and everything but look at
you celebrating uh
that's very festive
but just let me say I mean it is really
important because affirmative action
although it may have had good motivation
to the beginning and it's dressed up
it's very positive it is inherently
racist racism is part of its DNA it was
actively discriminating against white
people and Asians and it was really
patronizing to black people so the fact
that it might be over is a wonderful
thing I just hope it goes up to
corporations and the military and all
those other organizations and
institutions that are affected by
positive discrimination I'm going to
read a post by Michelle Obama in just a
moment and she really echoed a lot of
the katanji brown Jackson sort of
neo-racism on this nonsense but Douglas
to your point on the corporations uh do
you think this now starts a chain
reaction where corporations maybe even
just by themselves now that there'll be
some sort of cultural Awakening like
more and more people would be like yes
this was racist I was afraid to say it
all along but now that it seems like it
has a little momentum that corporations
might actually do the right thing on
their own and get rid of some of these
diversity Equity inclusion departments
without a court order to do so
uh well here's the thing they have a
little bit of an excuse that Joe Biden
the president has given them a bit of an
excuse by when he was asked in the Oval
Office uh just yesterday as we're
speaking uh about whether or not the
Supreme Court was a rogue Court
um he entertained the idea for some time
and then of course insulted the court in
a different way now there may well be
many people in America who will indeed
decide
you know Supreme Court Supreme Court uh
um who are they to say what we should do
there may be some corporations and
others who do that and I would expect a
certain amount of hold out and claim
that this is a rogue Supreme Court and
much more and nevertheless a judgment
has has occurred I would expect that
what we will see will be a gradual
reversal but it's going to have to be
pushed it will not happen
um organically because there are too
many people who've gone all in do you
think those die departments and all of
those incorporation after Corporation
are just going to come to work sometime
next week and say I'm so sorry
so I'm going to give it up today I'm
going to go and flip Burgers I of course
not they are the these people have the
the all of the diversity inclusion
Equity people are on the biggest
greatest Boone dog our time they're all
paid much more than the most of their
colleagues to tell everyone absolute rot
so I don't think they're just going to
give up their terrain uh freely even
after a Supreme Court decision I think
it's going to have to be pushed and I
would earn
um people at these corporations as with
other universities and so on to start
taking legal actions of their own new
Supreme Court precedent this door must
be pushed very very firmly now it's been
opened and we shouldn't expect it'll
just happen
Peter I know you were you were banned
probably in a very positive way from
Twitter for about two years you are back
on Twitter now and I was you know
navigating Twitter yesterday and
watching the amount of progressive left
these Democrats whatever you want to
call them at this point really openly
being for racism at this point let's
even just put aside white people for a
moment the idea that you are punishing
some Asian kid who worked really hard
whose parents maybe owned a little
Bodega as a lot of the Asian families in
my neighborhood growing up did a little
a little Mom and Pop Shop came with
nothing from say South Korea uh worked
really hard the open racism that these
kids should be punished because of
literally the color of their skin but
that that I guess doesn't really
surprise you right no not at all and
it's that level of cognitive dissonance
that is just staggering slush so
entertaining I mean I was looking at
some tweets yesterday and there was worn
by one called Erica Marsh who was a
former who was the former staffer of
Biden right yeah and she was on and of
course she was a she was a white middle
class young liberal woman and she was
like oh you know this is terrible how
will black people ever be able to thrive
and succeed without the help of us white
saviors and I was like oh my goodness
please stop stop she literally she
literally said black people will not be
allowed to will not get ahead with based
on Merit I mean that's that's white
supremacist type stuff but let me let me
read this post that Michelle Obama put
up uh because it illustrates some of the
katanji brown uh Jackson thinking here
she wrote back in college I was one of
the few black students on my campus and
I was proud of getting into such a
respect in school I knew I'd worked hard
for it but still I sometimes wondered if
people thought I'd got there because of
affirmative action it was a shadow that
students like me couldn't shake whether
those doubts came from The Outsider
inside our own minds but the fact is
this I belonged and semester after
semester decade after decade for more
than half a century countless students
like me showed they belong to it wasn't
just the kids of color who benefited
either every student who heard a
perspective they might not have
encountered who had an assumption
challenged who had their minds and their
hearts opened gained a lot as well it
wasn't perfect but there's no doubt that
it helped offer new ladders of
opportunity for those who throughout
history have too often been denied a
chance to show how fast they can climb
of course students on my campus and
countless others across the country were
and continue to be granted special
consideration for admissions some have
parents who graduated from the same
school others have families who can
afford coaches to help them run faster
hit a ball harder others go to high
schools with lavish sources for tutors
and extensive standardized test prep
that helps them score higher on college
entrance exams we don't usually question
if those students belong so often we
just accept that money power and
privilege are perfectly justifiable
forms of affirmative action while kids
growing up like I did are expected to
compete when the ground is anything but
level so today my heart breaks for any
young person out there who's wondering
what their future holds and what kind of
chances will be open to them and while I
know the strength and grit that lies
inside kids who have always had to sweat
a little more to climb the same ladders
I hope and I pray that the rest of us
are willing to sweat a little too today
is a reminder that we've got to do the
work not just to enact policies that
reflect our values of equity and
fairness but to truly make those values
real in all of our schools workplaces
and neighborhoods Douglas I read this
like three times and I I try to give the
devil his due and and Grant a little bit
of what she's saying there's some I
suppose nugget of Truth in there to some
extent but first off she ends by saying
Equity instead of equality which will
means we all end up in the same place
that's very different than us all
starting in the same place but also this
notion that even if everything she said
there was factually right
that we still should solve this by
punishing Asian and white students it
just makes no sense and apart from the
sheer emetic quality of her prose as
ever I don't know why
um Michelle Obama always feels this
desire to sort of throw herself into
debates like this I mean she's the
former first lady
um uh I don't know are we all waiting to
hear from Laura Bush
no because she had an s.a.t prep person
I'm sure and you know how that means
Melania Trump should weigh in soon on
her thought I mean she's a former first
lady she
um got where she did uh through all
sorts of memes uh but the idea that this
means that she has the sort of soapbox
about the Supreme Court I find as I say
it's a romantic among other things but
but here's the thing she she admits
something very strange but interesting
at the beginning of that
long-winded statement which is she says
that when she was at University she
sometimes wondered whether she had got
there through Merit now as I said in my
column in the New York Post today that's
one of the many secondary effects of
affirmative action is that it suggests
to many people black and not black that
the black students may actually be
lesser than in essential and cognitive
ability than the others and have been
only able to get there because they've
had an unnatural Boost from the
admissions process so that that as
Michelle Obama shows is something which
actually far from you know giving you
the strength to climb the ladder and all
of those other banal Hallmark cards
insights that Michelle Obama forever
gives people actually
detonate something at the beginning of
your University career which is a maybe
I'm not here on my own Merit and here's
one of many I think there's much to say
about this but
um see
things through the race lens now he
herself is an exceptionally privileged
person she her she is married to one of
the most privileged people in the world
their children when applying for college
I think they've already done that but
should they be regarded as right black
applicants to Harvard or wherever or
should their
extraordinarily privileged in fact more
privilege than anyone else in the world
probably apart from the Duke and Duchess
of Montecito should they be regarded as
being
highly privileged and therefore marked
down here's one final thing on this what
all these people get wrong is that at
universities across America
all of that is already taken into
account before you have to put race in
on missions
disproportionately actually doesn't not
put forward white students despite
counting for 70 of the adult population
the population as a whole in America
Harvard students only constitute 34
white now so we can play these games the
point is is that the University
admissions in in America and Britain
already take into account things like
socioeconomic background the advantages
you might have had from certain
schooling uh um and much more so
Michelle Obama's totally confused about
this and as so often is railing against
dead ghosts I mean a dead Phantom
menaces Harvard is desperate to include
in increase
black American
um right well let's not let's not forget
that this is the woman who said that she
was never proud of America until the day
her husband took office I mean that that
was a pretty uh telling statement right
there uh but to uh further Douglas's
point there Peter uh this concept that a
rich black kid who grew up in Malibu in
a 20 million dollar home he would be
given preference put aside the Obama
kids for a second he would be given
preference at Harvard over say some
white kid who grew up in the in the
sticks of West Virginia I mean this is
the most anti-American concept you could
possibly come up with it's absolutely
anti-American you've hit the nail on the
head there and it's also ludicrous I
mean if you look at the
intersectionality charts The Matrix
everything on paper about the Obamas
would list them as the oppressor class
apart from their race you think how on
Earth can this be calculable it doesn't
make any sense and that letter in itself
from Michelle Obama I found was really
sinister it was like smiling assassin
kind of stuff I actually wondered
whether maybe Stephen King had wrote it
because it was really eerie I mean
especially that
I'm thinking about Equity not equality
like it sounds like equality on the page
it looks like equality but it means a
very very different thing and you have
to ask yourself why is a recent form of
facility of the US promoting the idea
was it's essentially socialist slash
communist it's very very very
questionable and also I really didn't
like the way she was talking about how
she was implying victimhood as part of
her at her time at Princeton she got
into Princeton when she wasn't
necessarily the best candidate for that
role and part of the reason she got that
place on at the University is because
her elder brother was a star athlete at
Princeton he greased the whales for her
access into the university and that's
how she got ahead so she herself has
benefited from privilege she's such a
hypocrite by the way the Obamas the
Obamas are confused about a lot of
things because they also live on a
30-acre estate on the water in Martha's
Vineyard and with climate change you
know just rampaging the way it is the
house could be gone before you know it
but let's get something can I just very
quickly say something yeah there's
something that also needs to be pointed
out about this the rhetoric Michelle
Obama uses is the same rhetoric that her
husband uses and it's actually a very
very anti uh meritocratic rhetoric which
is this it's this I believe in you you
are amazing you kids you have so much
inside of you I believe in you I'm
praying for you
no no I mean no I mean what would you
mean I mean there'll be lazy kids and
hard-working kids they'll be brilliant
kids and stupid kids they'll be they'll
be
um um people who take every opportunity
they see and people who piss on every
opportunity they see that's
that's saying look if you get where you
want to get to in life it'll be the
result of your hard work your
aspiration your your your your ambition
and an awful lot more it's not just this
you're the magical wonderful you and
hopefully everyone's gonna realize it
someday I mean that is just such
soporific rubbish and I hate hearing it
and even if you were the magical
wonderful you that doesn't give the
state or a university the right to
discriminate against some other kid
because you're so filled with unicorn
dust and whatever else there you know
hopping the kids up on all right but
let's get some of the reaction from the
uh mainstream media here is uh Al
Sharpton who is
uh he is a well he's a race huckster and
also a host on the televised mental
institution known as MSNBC but here he
is in his limo uh because I guess this
was all happening on the Fly well I
think uh
this is 10 amount to sticking a dagger
in our back because what they have said
now is that it is unconstitutional to
even consider race this is a tremendous
setback that must be resisted by every
corner including the Department of
Justice and including States
if it wasn't for considering race this
guy this guy would have no gig but it's
just so funny because the things that
Martin Luther King Jr were fighting
against the idea that universities would
have quotas to keep black people out
things of that nature are now the exact
things that in 2023 when we basically
put racism to bed Douglas I think it's
you that always say but they're you know
they're keeping it on life support
um here he is making the racist argument
as the anti-racist Peter again it's just
yeah here we go and of course did you
notice how he was not only doing it in
the back of a limousine but he was also
doing it while wearing a five thousand
dollar suit now that's the kind of
Oppression it was like a 75 jacket by
the way right I mean yeah I could get
into that kind of impression you know
yeah I could do that don't need also
love I mean this is a man let's remember
I don't think we need to linger over the
so-called Reverend Al Sharpton this is
so Shameless that whenever a young black
man in America dies he literally pushes
his way to the front of the funeral
Cortez and will be standing in front of
the family at the coffin of a person he
never knew trying desperately to get his
bit of the action I mean
this is a man who's Shameless for a
living and of course he's Furious uh
that uh that uh in one way that people
are calling out the kind of race
huckstering that he's done but as you
say Dave if if if if if this kind of
so-called anti-racist racism didn't
exist whether the Reverend Al Sharpton
uh wouldn't have any reason to get into
his limousine in the morning there's a
phrase that I love that most people
credit uh Bill Maher for but believe it
or not it was George W bush the soft
bigotry of low expectations uh and watch
this clip this is also from MSNBC this
is contributor Eddie goude on what will
now happen at the universities we will
return to uh Elite institutions more
more specifically uh being the space for
a particular population for
predominantly white and Asian students
we will begin to see a kind of
segregated uh higher education landscape
and the irony of course as I try to I've
anticipated this decision but to hear it
I'm kind of still I'm trying to manage
my emotions but you know
this was just one remedy affirmative
action the only remedy to the legacy of
discrimination and admissions in
American higher education
Peter S Douglas pointed out first first
off we are a predominantly white Society
so for the people that want to just put
us in the boxes if that if you just care
about race then our schools would be
predominantly white because we're a
predominantly white country that's just
how it is
um but this this concept somehow that
what this guy is saying he he's actually
saying the most depressing thing you
could say to a young black person or a
brown person which is yeah it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter how hard you
work you're never going to make it which
is so contrary to the millions and
millions of black people who have
succeeded and become Millionaires and
own their own businesses and everything
else it's it's like it's most
soul-crushing way of viewing the world I
think exactly and
if you look at the data for University
admissions
white men are almost invisible on
University campuses that they are no
longer really going to University
they've opted out of Academia so I don't
know where he's getting this idea from
that University is going to be overrun
by terrible awful oppressive white
people most most white men are not going
to college so he's got nothing to worry
about and furthermore most universities
are Beyond Redemption anyway so why is
he even worried you might as well burn
them all down assault the Earth well
apart from and you know and then you
just go straight into coding by the way
um there's also something interesting
about what he said he said they'll go
back to being Elite institutions I have
news for him Harvard University is meant
to be an elite Institute
universities by their nature are meant
to be elite institutions in the same way
that sports teams are meant to be elite
institutions you do not
arrange the National Baseball League
make it a totally Equitable uh anyone of
any height and weight and speed can join
you know I like Elites
if they are earned if they have earned
their place I like Elites in Academia I
want Academia to be filled with Elites
the people who are the best at their
subject I like Elites in sports I do not
want to watch very overweight tiny
midgets trying to play basketball it
would not interest me for the record
wait wait wait wait for the record I
would love to watch tiny overweight
midgets play basketball like I'm totally
down with that it brought us down with
that too it once yeah I know like that
theme come on that's funny like a bunch
of overweight midgets playing basketball
I'll pay for that
well yeah it's great
great are important we need to have
Elites and this is this gets to the Crux
again of what judge Clarence Thomas
wrote in his in his job
not only
is what Harvard and other universities
and corporations Across America been
doing in contravention of the 14th
Amendment which occurred after the Civil
War but
it is perfectly clear that this is a
wider societal problem in America where
people don't believe in certain sectors
such as Academia and other very high
status professions that that that Merit
has to be the best and most important
criteria that is discretely why America
will become less competitive on the
world stage are Rivals and competitors
outside of the other Western countries
are focused on producing Elites
exceptional people who are at the top of
their game if America wants to play the
game of producing the basketball
player I can tell you how that ends
yeah the point is that uh Tick Tock for
Chinese kids is very different than Tick
Tock for American kids but that that's a
whole other topic but let's continue
with this race thing because if people
want to see how the over racialization
of everything really degrades society
and crushes people's thinking uh this is
a story that I saw last week and I
really wanted to hit on with you guys
there was a young girl by the name of
Jen Angel who was murdered by a black
man and she was a lefty and a social
justice Warrior and everything else and
that's what her friends are and now her
friends are lobbying to free the man
that murdered her it's unbelievably
extraordinary take a look at this clip a
reverse was Angel's friend she's one of
several people calling on local
authorities to pursue an alternative to
traditional prosecution I know Jen
believed that
we need to address harm and create
accountability that is that is really
rooted in in
looking at the root causes of why harm
happens burst says Angel strongly
disagreed with the current criminal
justice system and would not want her
alleged killer to go to prison like
locking somebody in a cage is that
really
gonna bring Jen back instead burst says
Angel would have liked a form of
restorative justice to happen friends of
angels have been working alongside the
non-profit restore Oakland and
restorative justice is really about
healing and Healing Begins with telling
the truth and our current Criminal
Justice System robs any opportunity of
truth-telling from all parties
just to be clear it was the it was the
murderer who was 19 years old I think
she was in in her 30s but uh Peter this
story like this they have a dead friend
and their concern is that the the
perpetrator of this murder somehow not
be treated poorly basically should just
walk out there like is this not just the
perfect
um end game of all of this nonsense all
right well two points on this Dave one
is that this is proof further proof that
progressivism is a mental disorder and
number two I think it's what you call
um pathological altruism when you have
when you have so much good intention
that it goes beyond the realm of what's
beneficial and becomes negative you know
and there seems to be a recurring theme
with the left we saw it only recently
when they were talking about abortion
they wanted so much tolerance that it
became a bad thing yes tolerance is good
of course it's good but there is such a
thing as too much tolerance and finding
that distinction is a fine political art
and for some reason liberals don't seem
to be able to do it and here we are with
this you know they're saying oh no you
know this this poor man he shouldn't be
held accountable for his actions well of
course he should because he's committed
a crime and I you know there is there is
a rule of law in America and these are
the very same people who when George
Floyd was killed were calling for his
killer to be arrested and tried and
potentially killed so not only are they
diluted but they also have inconsistent
principles it's like I want to get all
liberals together in a conference room
get them to decide on what their
principles are come out and debrief the
rest of the world on it because then we
can actually move forward with the
conversation but I mean this really is a
case of pathological altruism and it's
almost exclusive to the left yeah
Douglas Jordan Peterson talks about this
a lot you've written about it that you
know basically if in your hierarchy of
values you put tolerance at the top you
actually become the most intolerant
person what would you say to someone
like if you were sitting in a room with
a friend trying to explain to her why
perhaps this is not the best way uh to
get Justice for her friend or to solve
any of these problems how do we
deprogram some of these people or do we
just have to let a certain segment of
the society go well the first thing is
the geology didn't care about her friend
very much
um just obviously not she cares about
her own narcissistic self-presentation
more than she does about her her
friend's murder the second thing is
she's obviously other the friends of
this poor and clearly don't understand
the most basic point of Justice or
indeed the criminal justice system the
criminal justice system is not in place
in order to heal
it is not in place in order to provide
some Cosmic social justice the primary
purpose of imprisonment imprisonment is
punishment is punishment for crime uh
secondarily among other things if the
person somewhere down the line who
perpetrated the crime can realize the
atrocity they have committed and feel
some kind of regret for it that's not a
bad thing but that's not the purpose of
the Criminal Justice System it is to
punish people for wrongdoing and
murdering somebody is hitherto generally
been regarded as quite serious
wrongdoing and so if you do it you
should expect the most extreme
punishment and in America that can
include capital punishment uh or it can
include it should include life
imprisonment
um these people's brains have been
totally deranged of course uh but as I
say
I've come across this before I wrote
about it in my 2017 bestseller the
strange death of Europe where I gave
examples of something similar which was
um some a number of women
who had been helping illegal migrants to
break into Europe and were then raped by
some migrants this is of course as we
always have to say the inevitable
disclaimer not all of the migrants were
rapists but some were and there was an
Italian activist in particular I
remember she was a raped by uh one of
the migrants she'd helped to come in and
her colleagues encouraged her to cover
over the rape and she did because she
felt that if she talked about the fact
or indeed went to the authorities to say
she'd been raped
um then it might reflect badly on her
rapist so next thing you know everyone
has been raped and nobody knows that
anyone else has been raped that's pretty
much where you end up I want to do one
other thing uh before we move on to
Biden with you guys because today guys
this is very exciting June 30th the last
day of June it's the last day of Pride
and finally we can go back to 330 some
odd days of Shame which frankly are much
better but but when people talk about
social justice just going completely off
the rails uh obviously there's been all
these Pride parades the last couple
weeks check out this clip is this from
New York City Pride yeah this is from
New York City Pride and listen to what
these people are chanting
[Music]
yeah
we're here
[Music]
all right I suppose the quiet part out
loud I assumed that was a man with the
breasts there were guys hanging out with
their wangs out in front of children all
of the stuff
um you know guys when I booked this show
and happened to be today the last day of
Pride I didn't even realize actually the
three of us happened to be gay I would
just say happened to be because we're
all friends and it actually doesn't
really come up that often when we're
having dinner or having drinks or
whatever it's just a part of our lives
but this this LGBT thing has done
something so freaking dangerous I would
say to us that it is starting to become
personal to me uh Peter how do we
separate from the lunatics here before
before the decent people on the right
who I think have come a long way on a
lot of this stuff start turning on on
the average gay per the average G and B
and L
well festivals I think we all need to
return on membership cards because I no
longer want to be part of this group
anymore this is absolutely crazy but I
think it's really nice that you think
more and more people
they're all gay or lesbian or bisexual
rejecting this narrative that is so
extreme and also that has embraced
transgenderism which as we've discussed
is a completely different part of Human
Experience I mean it's it's never has
anything to do with sexuality it's not
actually part of sexuality it's
something completely different so I
think it's really nice for people like
yourselves like Douglas to speak up to
address these things and really tackle
them head-on and disassociate and
moderate and modulate the narrative
that's happening
Douglas what do we do about this
situation I I think if I'm not mistaken
you tweeted about it not too long ago
like this thing where I can sense that
people on the right who just who came a
long way maybe they weren't cheering gay
marriage but it happened and then they
were just like all right live your life
just you know stay away from our kids in
essence you don't have to teach people
this just just live your life which is
what I thought the a just movement for
equality was all about that's what I'm
concerned about that because of these
the way these letters have been mashed
together they're going to turn and and I
don't know what the force field against
that will be well first of all I never
had membership of this yeah no me
neither I'm just saying they they Jam
these freaking letters together yeah I I
and there also is no such thing as an
lgbtqia plus person it just isn't uh
they don't exist it's a triple clown car
made up of a bunch of now dominated
certainly by a bunch of very angry
Misfits that uh clip you showed there
was there a single gay man in that I
don't think so right right see it was uh
people who call themselves queer who
very often are actually straight and
anarchists in some way they have no
connection to gay men or gay women uh
they believe that they need to draw
attention to themselves and bring down
the patriarchy and everything like that
that has nothing to do with being gay I
wrote about this in The Madness of
crowds where I said then there's always
been a divide in the game gay rights
movement as there was in Civil Rights
Movement between people who believed in
in basic equality and that was it and
those who believed that it was the
beginning of a step to pull down a
society now uh the Reverend Martin
Luther King and others dealt with this
in the civil rights movement and got
that out unfortunately in the gay rights
movement after the point of Victory
basically these these Misfits uh have
taken over because everybody else has
got a life to get on with and so the the
weirdo clown car people are now actually
toxify buying everyone else in the
alphabet soup that they're involved with
I think it is actually going to get
quite serious it's why I think that
people like me you know frankly as you
say David I mean are not very interested
in talking about sexuality because it's
not the most interesting thing I've got
books I want to read about other
subjects but the point is is that is
that we actually do have to speak out
about this because I think that a lot of
people particularly conservatives May
well be saying and I've seen them saying
it in recent weeks you know we were kind
of lied to yeah wanted equality and now
we see like we're coming for your
children
um and children are quite understandably
the tripwire on this parents do not want
their children to be indoctrinated into
any particular ideology in my experience
particularly not into the Mad gender
woo-woo ideology which was only a few
years ago and so there is a backlash I
think it's encumbered upon everyone who
happens to be gay and hasn't have any
public profile to say actually
um I'm going to do what in my favorite
seen in Master and Commander happens
when the ship's Captain realizes that
the person on the raft pulling the the
whole ship is going to capsize the whole
shift the ship uh you get the act and
you cut the rope cut to the Rope every
LGB person should cut the rope get these
people away from us we do not want the
gender Misfit woo-woo ideologues we
don't want these mad deranged
self-identified queers who want to bring
down the the nation the country and
everything else we don't them anywhere
near us uh that that it just can't be
said enough because otherwise this is
going to become more and more toxic and
I just had one other thing Dave you said
it's the last day of pride month it used
to be a pride parade it became Pride day
it then became Pride week now it's pride
month uh and Justin Trudeau who would
love to identify as queer I'm quite
um Justin no just the other day referred
to Pride season so
soon to be Pride year and my patience is
a long run out on this so I can only
imagine what the patients of most
ordinary straight people must be at this
stage yeah so Peter let me give you the
last word on this because I we're all I
know we have no doubt that all of us are
in agreement with what Douglas just said
right there in terms of disconnecting
from this thing but is there is the
inherent problem from disconnecting from
movements is that the hysteric people
the hysterical people are always making
the headlines they're the ones out there
screaming and everything else and guys
like the three of us are out there
working and and doing functional things
the way most gay people who are actually
quite similar to straight people and
want the same things dignity and
self-respect and equal rights so so
there's an asymmetry there where you're
always going to look at the most rabid
crazy person and then unfortunately that
infects everybody so the the using the
ax to cut the rope uh it doesn't often
happen because people are busy living
their lives right and like Douglas said
that's why I think a lot of people like
us have a duty to do something and to
speak out and movements throughout
history have always needed to trim the
fast to to get rid of the extremists on
the fringes because they've had
counterproductive uh you know elements
on the movement itself and that needs to
happen even now we need to constantly be
reassessing the politics of
homosexuality and everything else
because otherwise it gets co-opted by
other groups who are Bad actors and have
got malignant intent and one other thing
to say by the way uh I want to say is
very clearly all the people who dress as
like the queer
um uh you know walking down the street
weird uh Anarchist uh I'm a bloke but
I'm gonna wear nipple tassels and so
okay nobody wants to sleep with you
[Laughter]
do a call back to the uh fat midgets
here but we're just going to move to the
next segment which is about the elderly
man pretending to be president uh Joe
Biden was on MSNBC yesterday and uh well
earlier in the week he said that Putin
has lost the war in Iraq but that was
not his worst flub because watch what
happened as they tried to go to
commercial free America where they voted
for me or not well and and the ones that
didn't vote for your bills but run on
them
Mr President thank you thank you thank
you very much thank you thank you
don't go anywhere it's a very exciting
day around here
um we'll have reaction and Analysis to
everything we just heard from
guys he makes Mr Burns look like Andrew
tank like this is just
Douglas how much longer can this charade
go on I mean this show it just does not
stop and apparently he's running again I
love the host saying don't go anywhere
yeah uh you
find his way out in the studio
um look I mean it it in some ways one
has to be careful about this because
it's getting into sort of elder abuse
territory at the moment the whole
Democratic party hierarchy is see what
you like about the Republican party
which goodness knows has its own
problems but it doesn't lack uh Talent
beneath the top level and it doesn't
lack people who know how to talk uh the
Democratic Party by contrast is is led
by somebody who it's just very sad
actually every day now there's another
bidenism the reason why he didn't seem
to know the rules of live television was
because he doesn't do it very often it
means that any president
um he uh he he uh he's got the 90 year
old Dan fan Einstein do I actually
admire in many ways a very distinguished
senator in the past from California
wheeled into the Senate recently doesn't
seem to realize that she hasn't been
there
um the Press aren't allowed to speak to
her he got John fetterman uh the senator
um uh from uh from Philadelphia who who
was at by the I-95 it was rebuild the
day uh standing beside Joe Biden he
seems fetterman seemed to refer to Joe
Biden as the collapsed Bridge which
I mean it's not
um and uh and and then you've got Kamala
Harris always on hand to give us a long
disquisition about the nature of time
and and it is very interesting when Owen
Kamal Harris talks about the nature of
time because time slows down
whenever she does so in fact it almost
grinds to a halt
um but yeah I mean the party's in a mess
and the the the the the the older
Generation The Binding generation is
holding on my prediction is actually uh
that he's not going to be running
they're going to get him and camel out
and it's going to be as pleasant as they
can do it but it'll be pretty brutal so
I have said I said it the day of
inauguration he was not going to run the
second time around or that he would not
have a second term and and I think
finally I've been saying for a couple of
months now it will start trickling out
to the media the sort of push him out
thing and what I thought was going to
happen it would be something like Obama
would be in an interview and just
casually say boy you know Joe's lost a
step and that would be the trigger then
for the media to start going with it but
I think something did I think something
happened this week that actually is the
trigger on that which is that it has
been reported that Joe Biden is using a
CPAP machine this is this machine that
you strap on your face at night if
you're snoring a lot and it helps you
breathe here's a quick little CBS thing
on that in Washington the White House
today announced that President Biden is
using a device for his sleep apnea an
official said the president has been
using a CPAP machine which stands for
continuous positive airway pressure in
order to help improve his breathing
during sleep the information came up to
reporters noticed these indentations on
the president's face this morning caused
by the apparatus according to the
American Medical Association about 30
million Americans suffer from sleep
apnea
I mean my God it looks like he's got
like Bane's mask on his face with that
thing but I want to read a tweet by Mike
cernovich because he basically said what
I've been pushing for quite some time he
said the green light went out a week or
so ago now it's full-scale attack from
regime media in essence like oh we got
Biden in we used him properly and now
there's the green light to sort of show
him out and then Usher in either Gavin
or whatever else is coming Peter do you
think that's where we're at at this
point like it's about to happen yeah
this feels very very odd the media
absolutely did not need to report on
this issue it's kind of a complete known
story they really didn't need to give it
any Oxygen the fact that they have
raises more questions I think is this
the thin end of the word are they now
starting to ask why isn't I suspect so I
think so that cenovich is probably right
and Douglas is also correct in the sense
that there really isn't that much talent
beneath my did Kathleen Kamala she
certainly can't do the job Stacey Abrams
she can't do that
he can't do the job so who's left
thankfully I do think there might be a
bit of Salvation in Robert F Kennedy
maybe I think although
yeah no look he's way better but I don't
you know I don't know if you saw his
reaction to the affirmative action
decision yesterday but he basically said
it was the wrong decision so you know
he's got his own limitations but Douglas
what do you think what do you think the
move is like how is it that they're
gonna push they have to push Kamala out
right so you have to it's the Democrats
who will take out the first black female
vice president to somehow get the white
guy Gavin Newsom in that's right you
can't you can't this is why I go back I
think Sunridge is wrong on this I you
can't do this brutally and in public it
has to be done behind the scenes
um uh people I speak to suggest that the
the thing to look for is of course we
have Hunter Biden um doing a a deal uh
with a DHA over the most minor issues
which was uh some tax evasion and gun
ownership
um there's a lot more of course in the
hunter bible stuff and in the Biden
families General pay for play stuff now
the thing to watch for is when Democrats
stop holding back the Republicans and
doing everything they want in terms of
the investigation into the Biden family
at that point some of the Democrats will
speak to Biden and say
um the way to make this go away is to
step away now what do you do with the
problem like Kamala yeah the only thing
you can do because you can't as you say
the Democratic party cannot be seen to
be stopping the first minority female
vice president from herself running if
she wants to there isn't a vacancy on
the Supreme Court at the moment but
there could be and there's one Justice
in particular who if she was called back
into the White House could be persuaded
to step down early and Kamala Harris
could be slotted into the Supreme Court
um that's the most plausible Pleasant
way in which you deal with the Biden
Harris ticket being effectively ushered
off the stage the the Democratic party
as we know from the DNC hacks some years
ago is a lethally effective when it
would be and I think that they are
starting to realize that the bidenisms
are not on a weekly or a monthly basis
but a daily basis now and party is
sensible enough to know they cannot go
into an election with a with a
presidential candidate who is all the
time literally one footstep away from
disaster
uh uh Peter I don't think I can end the
show on that deeply depressing note that
Kamala Harris is going to be a Supreme
Court Justice so you've got to give me
something pithy to end this program on
please
um
we should have just thrown to the Kamala
cackle there to end the show that would
have been it
well I guess may God have mercy on our
souls how about that
'll do
gentlemen it has been a pleasure uh we
are going to link to your books down
below and I thank you guys we're gonna
do a post game show right now at
reubenreport.locals.com for everybody
else uh no show on Monday I'm giving the
team off for July 3rd and then of course
uh no show on Tuesday for the fourth and
we'll be back on Wednesday so thanks
again to Douglas and Peter and thanks
you guys for watching adios
please
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign